all they want right now yeah the water
loads can find the basket and posting up
Kauai on the inside and Hawai Leonard's
got 17 oh and you look at the shots that
he does get he should shoot a high
percentage and is so good again to the
bucket how about that that's a strength
saying get out of my way I think Rubio's
died do more of that now instead of
always looking to pass
take those take those lamps Kauai how
sweet it is outer on the inside doesn't
go moose doing a good job keeping it
alive he was the head coach of the San
Antonio Spurs G League team he's got
30-plus in 2x and watches he picks up
that ball gets the body contact as he
knows Exim doesn't have the position he
needs and how about moose at the other
end if you can't get it just make sure
they can't get it keeping that ball
alive leading it out 16th year that's
unbelievable 16th year second-round pick
there's Kauai he has got a 34 quick but
don't hurry
exactly Guillen huh well John wouldn't
basketballs game of speed and quickness
but you never rush yeah so tough shot
Leonard's got 36 really hasn't gotten on
track 16 to 20 in this game Crowder has
it's a call by 30
you know how strongly gonna be true and
then the left this is spectacular
contact all the way and somehow able to
stretch and get that ball in clean
without using the glass wow that's
impressive into the frontcourt
quick move driving on angles letter 44